RESPECTIVE TEAM ONE-ON-THREE ATE
MOMENT.
TO BRAD HUNT WITH A STEP ON THE
LEFT WING, CUTTING IN OY,
J.T. MILLER GOES BACKHAND THE PK
BEHIND THE GOAL.
LAMMIKKO MOVES IN TO PRESSURE AD
THATCHER DEMKO,RED 26-11, AND Y,
MYERS CHECKED BY SHARANGOVICH.VE
MYERS ON THE SECOND ATTEMPT
WORKS THE PUCKOWN, KNOCKED OUT F
THE AIR BY HAMONIC.
NOT A HIGH STICK SAYS THEDEVILSD
TO GET AROUND PETAN.
MICHAEL MCLEOD WITH A WRIST
SHOT, THAT DIDN'T MISSS SIDE,
SHARANGOVICH GETS IT AND SENDS
IT ACROSS TO TIME OF
THE FIFTH GOAL OF THEES ONE AROR
GARLAND, GARLAND BOBBLED THE THS
JACK HUGHES JUST P REVERSE, HOR,
BO HORVAT IN ON THE LEFT
PASS, AND UNDERNEATH THE ARM OF
NICO DAWS
BO HORVAT DID THE RIGHT THING.
>> John S.: MILLER GLOVESN.
MAKES THE PLAY AND THEN GETS THE
MILLER HAD TO TAKE THE PUCK OFF
THE BOARDS, HOOKS INTOO
GRAVES SENDS ONE AROUND FOR JACK
HUGHES, AND HE FLIPS THE AND A O
WORK ON POWER PLAY NUMBER TWO.US
FAILED TO CLEAR AS THEY SHOT SH.
MILLER HAS ANOVAT THROUGH CENTRE
SHORTHANDED IN ON GOAL, SCORES!N
HUGHES KILLING PENALTIES, AND B.
LUKE SCHENN PUTS IT OFF THE SIDE
OF THE GOAL.
THERE'S THE SHOT BY LUKE SCHENN